Okay, so I'm a big fan of CAR-T cell therapy, but I'm also a big fan of Bispecific.
So why do we have to choose one or the other?
So today I'll be talking about a trial that we have ongoing at MGB of L-renatumab, the
BCMA Bispecific, as a consolidation after Idacel.
So, you know, this is a question that's been brought up, you know, now, you know, is there
ever a situation to actually use Idacel over Siltacel for our myeloma patients?
Well, reason one, maybe to enroll them onto this trial.
Reason number two, though, is, you know, there are select patients who are particularly risk
adverse, and they can be concerned about that small risk of severe or irreversible toxicity
that can come with Siltacel in the form of non-ICANS
neurotoxicity, enterocolitis, and secondary hematologic malignancies.
And we want to make, so, you know, we have Idacel, we know it's not as efficacious as
Siltacel, but so what are strategies that we can use to improve CAR-T cell efficacy?
Well, you can make new, better CAR-T cells, and we have other CAR-T cells in the pipeline,
but, you know, we can't wait forever.
You could think about adjunct therapies.
During the CAR-T cell process, or you can think about consolidation or maintenance
approaches after CAR-T.
And so that's where we're going to focus as a consolidation after CAR-T.
We know for Idacel, like many other therapies, the depth of response correlates with the
duration of response.
So in the CARMA studies, you know, patients who actually got a CR, a stringent CR after
Idacel, their median PFS was 19 months, which is, you know, much higher than the median
PFS.
Of 13 months.
And, you know, biospecific antibodies, you know, are almost a common sense partner as
consolidation after CAR-T cells.
They have very complementary mechanisms of action.
So the idea here is that, you know, you could harness the activity of the CAR-T cells that
are also, that are already there, or you can induce polyclonal T cell expansion to deepen
the response.
And that's kind of the principle, the concept behind the epigenetic response.
Here, the biospecific antibodies are trying to reinvigorate that polyclonal T cell expansion
and improve the CAR-T cell persistence that's there.
And then rather than giving it as a continuous kind of maintenance approach, here we're using
a fixed duration consolidation approach to avoid overtreatment, to prevent T cell exhaustion,
and to really, you know, you know, promote that principle of one and done or extended
time off therapy.
That would be the principle.
And then rather than giving it as a continuous kind of maintenance approach to avoid overtreatment,
most patients are getting, starting ELRA at about three months after IDASEL.
And it's six cycles of ELRA.
So the first two cycles are weekly, and then the four, the four following cycles are every
two weeks, primary endpoint progression-free survival.
And we allow patients to do the ELRA step-up dosing as an outpatient or as an inpatient.
So, so far, we've, you know, as our last data cut, you know, 20% of patients have been
tested.
So we've had about 20 patients had started ELRA consolidation, and about half of them
actually got their step-up dosing as an outpatient.
They started about three months after IDASEL.
And 13 patients have completed the ELRA treatment, and 17 patients were still having ongoing
treatment.
All right, so these are the patient characteristics.
Just a few things that I wanted to point out.
You know, about a third of the patients were 75 years or older.
So this is an older patient population.
The median prior lines of therapy is, you know, three.
So seems like a less heavily pretreated patient population, generally earlier line.
The majority of the patients, 85% received bridging therapy.
And almost half of the patients only had a partial response or stable disease after IDASEL.
This is our swimmer's plot.
So we have 19 evaluable patients here.
And, you know,
I just want to point out that we do have patients who are, you know, having durable responses after IDASEL, after ELRA.
So five patients have had an ongoing CR at 12 months after starting ELRA.
There's three patients here who have had an ongoing CR at 18 months after starting ELRA.
So that's basically like 21 months after IDASEL.
We've only had, of these 19 patients, only one patient has had progressive disease, which occurred about,
11 months from IDASEL.
And this patient actually, interestingly, only had a small subcutaneous plasmacytoma, which was excised.
They got localized local radiation therapy to the plasmacytoma site.
And then since then has actually remained off systemic therapy without further progression,
extramedullary or biochemically, and an MRD negative stringency are upwards to 22 months from,
their IDASEL.
And we see deepening of the CR rates of the response.
So of the 11 patients who started ELRA and VGPR or less, 82% had deepening of their response.
The MRD data is still premature, but among the three evaluable patients who had MRD positive disease at baseline,
and then evaluable MRD after,
completing ELRA, all had conversion to MRD negativity.
And of the evaluable patients, none have lost MRD negativity.
So the patients who went in MRD negative, they've remained MRD negative even six months post IDASEL.
So safety, you know, we see pretty low rates of CRS, 35% of patients had grade one CRS.
There was one patient at grade two CRS.
We don't see any ICANN.
And we don't see any, we haven't had any high grade CRS.
We do see hematologic toxicity in the forms of grade three, four neutropenia and 45% of the patients.
The big thing that we were really cognizant of is the infection risk.
So these are patients who have just gotten a BCMA targeted CAR-T cell therapy, and we're giving them a BCMA Bispecific.
So this is, you know, one thing that we're really watching closely, 65% of patients have had infections.
But only three patients or 15% have had grade three infections.
We've had one patient come off study because of infections.
He had disseminated VZV followed by cholecystitis, and she stopped ALRA.
20% of the patients have had CMV reactivation, but none required starting CMV directed treatment.
And 75% of the patients were getting IVIG repletion.
And now we're, it was recommended in the initial protocol, and now we've kind of like mandated it in an amendment.
So, you know, this is the conclusion.
The concept is viable.
You know, we can do fixed duration consolidation.
We're seeing deepening of responses, and we're seeing only like a moderate infection risk.
Obviously, we need longer follow up to see what the PFS is.
Is this better than, you know, if you were to do them sequentially, you know.
It's not a randomized trial, but that's kind of what we want to see.
And we're doing a lot of correlative work to look at the T cell dynamics in this consolidation strategy.
So this is, I just want to thank all of our huge team.